[Musique]
e
antemeta accompagne les entreprises dans
leurs services numériques que ce soit le
stockage ou encore la cyber sécurité
cette entreprise emploie 180
collaborateurs sur son siège à
guyancourt avec 90 millions de chiffre
d'affaires réalisés en 2019
c'est une entreprise en plein
développement et en plus elle agrandit
son bâtiment et nous sommes avec son
président et co fondateur stéphane blanc
bonjour bonjour nicolas vous avez bien
très bien merci et vous écoutez pas mal
[Musique]
antemeta se porte plutôt bien 460 mètres
carrés de plus en cours de construction
en ce moment exactement
on reconstruit effectivement une surface
importante pour accueillir nos activités
de soc et de nok tout on va dire
l'activité nécessitant un grand niveau
de sécurité est donc dans lequel on
souhaite également que nos
collaborateurs soit plus tôt qu'aucun et
voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu
l'objectif parce que la sécurité veut
pas dire que on n'est pas un bon espace
de travail juste un point soc noc
ouais qu'est ce que ça signifie alors le
soc a pour objectif de surveiller en
permanence l'intégralité du système
d'information de nos clients
d'accord qui sont connectés à travers
notre cloud de cloud privé de cloud
hybride ou de cloud public qui sont
connectés à travers le haut et puis le
nok et bien c'est la sécurité
alors non pas effectivement d'accès mais
c'est la sécurité en lui-même des
données ddd data c'est on va dire la
couche la couche inférieure du système
de production voilà il ya la couche
autres le le soc et le knock la couche
basse le socle à c'est ce qui se passe
ici nous sommes dans un sac voilà on a
volontairement on vous montre pas tout
parce que effectivement sécurisé c'est
quand même très sécurisé donc les
tableaux qui ont été choisis mais par
contre on est en temps réel ce que vous
voyez en sa fiche est effectivement en
temps réel ici sont le type de deux on
va dire d'un point de vue technique de
reniflard qui effectué par des tiers sur
les équipements dédiés à nos clients
voilà comme vous pouvez voir il ya
beaucoup d'activités reniflage c'est
repérer les les années folles les
failles
je repère des failles je vois en fait
c'est exactement comme une maison
considéré qu' il ya quelqu'un qui ouvre
essayé d'ouvrir les portes les fenêtres
de l'entente de l'intégralité de votre
maison pour voir s'il n'y a pas une
porte ou une fenêtre qui est ouverte
d'accord ces salles à partir des flashs
d'abord une partie de découverte s'en
suit derrière
en fonction de la situation on va voir
si on va passer par la fenêtre par la
cheminée
par des égouts voilà tout et tout est
possible c'est exactement comparer ça à
votre votre maison alors je le disais
vous agrandissez vos locaux mais c'est
accompagné aussi d'une grande vague de
recrutement chez vous alors il ya en
fait cet emplacement bâtiment sert à a
regroupé à la fois donc comme je vous le
disais le socle noc mais c'est aussi
parce que effectivement on est en train
de converger deux activités qui pour
nous sont stratégiques
l'activité de data management
anciennement activités back up d'accord
et l'activité soc notre sécurité mais
pour répondre à votre question donc
effectivement on regroupe du coup comme
regroupe ces deux activités on est en
train d'embaucher à peu près dix
personnes aujourd'hui qui regroupe à la
fois de la cyber mais aussi du data
management parce que c'est ça c'est
cette convergence qui a du sens
aujourd'hui au vu du niveau d' attaque
qu'on se prend en europe mais également
à l'étranger
un dernier mot stéphane blanc on l'a vu
une période compliquée c'était un étang
c'était la crise sanitaire compliqué
pour les entreprises qui ont dû se
réorganiser travailler en réseau avec le
télétravail est ce que vous avez eu un
impact sur votre activité
parce que qui dit réseau et travaillent
en réseau dit sécurité de ses réseaux
alors deux activités les chantiers matin
une activité négoce d'accord qui elle a
subi plus tôt une décroissance parce que
les projets ont été plus ou moins j'ai
par contre activités cloud services
managés ses sorties bien évidemment un
petit peu renforcé parce que
effectivement nos clients qui étaient
déjà dans notre cloud ou dans nos
services managés ou d'autres qui étaient
déjà client sonné une nécessité à venir
consommer en urgence des usages liés
effectivement au surplus de consommation
qu'impliquait les usages des de leurs
collaborateurs qui étaient en modèle
externaliser tout à fait voilà
effectivement là il ya eu un surplus de
sécurité et on n'a pas vu encore je suis
désolé d'être un peu de prédire un petit
peu l'avenir mais je pense que forcément
ça crée des failles de sécurité
bien évidemment pas forcément j'espère
chez nous mais je pense que ça crée des
failles de sécurité
voilà merci stéphane blanc je vous en
prie président et co-fondateur
d'antemeta